[music]
Our next speaker is VP of research at
Google DeepMind. Please join me in
welcoming to the stage Rya Hazdell.
>> [music]
[applause]
>> Hello everyone. Wonderful. Uh what a
lovely full room and good smiles. I
heard the uh dig on Google there at the
end. I I I I did catch that. Um so my
name is Rya Hadzel. Uh I've been a part
of uh DeepMind uh for the last uh almost
13 years and I'm very happy to have AI
engineer come here to London. I'm also
uh very proud this year to be a UK AI
ambassador. So I help the government um
academia industry sort of bridge those
those gaps. Um, and uh, yes, I'm
American by birth, but I've been here
for long enough um, that uh, can count
myself among the proud Brits as well.
So, I'm going to talk a little bit about
Frontier AI and the future of
intelligence.
Uh, to start a little bit of a of a
longer um, introduction to who I am. Uh,
it's good to be as old as I am. You get
to look at this by the decades. So in
the 90s I did my undergraduate degree in
philosophy of religion. Um was
definitely not uh not a computer
scientist yet. Um uh but I really
enjoyed it. Before you ask uh uh yes I
learned a lot and I'm glad that I did it
and no it hasn't been very useful since.
Um, in the 2000s I did a bit of a pivot
uh moved into computer science uh after
some some good advice from those close
to me and spent my PhD years in New York
City working on uh convolutional
networks, neural networks for robots uh
with uh with Yan Lun uh which is a lot
of fun. Um I then in the 2010s made the
decision to join a small group of uh
curious um scrappy uh individuals
working at Deep Mind. Um it's a group of
about um uh 30 40 people at the time and
uh we spent the rest of that decade
working on things like Atari video games
uh go Starcraft and some robotics. um a
lot of fun and um uh now I am a VP uh
within Deep Mind. I help run about a
group of about 1,200 scientists and
engineers um across 10 labs um um and uh
we're working on a lot of different
things. I will tell you about three of
those.
Um so first uh frontier AI is uh an area
where um we really are trying to make
sure that we are staying in the front.
So we're thinking about what are the
next architectures that we're going to
use for Gemini? What are the next
problems that only AI uh can really
address? Um and how are we going to
build the future of intelligence? And
that's thinking not just about
artificial intelligence but it's create
the future of human intelligence as well
and even robotics intelligence as well.
Um we are all on this uh journey
together and I think that it's important
to think about how how humans change as
well as the technology. Um our approach
we look for root nodes. You know we're
not going to waste time on the leaves.
We're going to really find for a big
problem space that hasn't been solved.
what are how deep can we go find the
deepest problems and solve those in
order to then enable um a lot of
downstream stream impact. Um we partner
you know really with the world. I really
think about it very broadly and think
about who are the partners that can help
us find those root nodes and solve those
problems and also you know bring it to
the to the leaf nodes and solving
problems that are worth solving. Um the
motto or the mission of deep mind um is
to build AI responsibly uh for the
benefit of humanity. So I really take
that seriously. We want to build build
uh solve problems that are worth
solving. Um all right. So uh we work in
a lot of different areas within Frontier
AI um in Deep Mind. These are sort of
some of the different uh categories. I'm
not going to tell you about all of them.
So you can uh just uh maybe keep those
in mystery. Um but I'll just pick out a
couple. So first in advanced models um I
actually wanted to uh bring up uh an
embedded model. So the theme of this
talk overall is things that are not
directly language models. Um and in the
modeling space I wanted to talk about
embedding models. To start that out I'll
ask if anyone knows what a Jennifer
Aniston cell is.
Aha. I got a few neuroscientists
neuroscientists in the room. So this is
actually a concept from neuroscience
um where we've discovered that uh there
are not just a single cell but a small
number of neurons that will encode for a
specific thing as in a specific person.
And that those combinations of neurons
that only activate for that one person
or that one thing or that one place,
those cells are actually very robust.
They uh activate regardless of modality.
Um and this is used by the brain very
very fast retrieval for recognition um
and for comparison functions. Uh, so
that means that when I say the name
Jennifer Aniston or if I showed you a
picture or a video or if you even heard
her voice, if you knew her, if you were
enough of a fan, then those all those
different modalities lead to the same
set of cells activating. Um, so we want
that in a artificial neural network um
for the same reason. We want fast
retrieval, recognition, and comparison.
Um and so we can trade what's called an
embedding model uh in order to encode
for those concepts in order to be more
robust um to different uh different ways
the information can be presented um and
to be very very good at sort of
understanding what is the comparison
between these different activations.
Use contrastive losses. One of the
reasons why I like this space is that
because I did my PhD work in part
looking at Siamese neural networks which
was an early way of understanding what
is a contrastive loss function. Um and
so these these embedding uh uh functions
are really critical companion to
generative AI. Sometimes we want to
generate, sometimes we want to retrieve.
Um, so the group at Google has been
working on this for a long time and just
recently we've actually released Gemini
embedded 2. So this is exciting to me
because it really is sort of the the
ideal. It is fully omnimodal.
Um, it uses uh it's derived from Gemini.
Um, so it's got sort of that level of of
knowledge and understanding of the world
and it is and it allows extremely
extremely good retrieval.
um uh in a little bit more more detail
then um why is it good that it is
unified and multimodal? It means that
you don't have to have different steps
to try to bring things together and ma
map them together. You can be truly
endtoend and not lose information by
trying to combine audio information,
visual information, text information
together.
Um, so you can get a single vector that
represents text,
uh, uh, up to 8,8K tokens,
>> [snorts]
>> um, uh, 128 seconds of video, 80 seconds
of audio, um, and a full PDF. And
together that can give you a lot of
information. You can then use that um to
be able uh to use it for retrieval
[snorts] um for for for querying um for
agentic logic and other things. Um we
also use something called the matri
matrioska representation learning MRL um
and that allows us to have diff be able
to have the same network but represent
different uh dimensions. So for
instance, you could start out doing a
retrieval uh using only uh 256
dimensions for your embedding and then
you can expand that to get to more
expressiveness.
Um
so uh this also this gives us we can
demonstrate that we have this allows us
to have a unified um semantic space um
and really state-of-the-art quality. Uh
so um just something that's come out
recently that I think should it doesn't
get talked about quite as often as
language models but it's really
important as that uh companion I think.
All right. [snorts]
Next I wanted to quickly talk about
another thing that is not a language
model. This is not a language model at
all. There's no language involved. Um
and this is work that we've done on the
weather. Uh in London it rains a lot.
Um, and a few years ago there was a um a
informatics uh scientist at the Met
Office, the meteorological office for
the UK, the UK's weather agency that
said, "Can you predict better rainfall
than our physics-based models
um using AI?" And I said, "I don't know.
Interesting problem. Let me take this
back to the team." Took this back to the
team. Um at Deep Mind we started working
on this and we discovered yes you know
what predicting the weather even though
it is a very very hard problem using a
physics simulation of the atmosphere is
actually quite tractable for neural
network models given that we have 40
years of data 40 years of global data on
what the weather is. Um so a couple of
years ago we came out with graphcast.
Um graphcast uh predicts the uh predicts
the state of the atmosphere up to 15
days out um everywhere on earth and for
many different variables. And this uses
a spherical graph neural network. uh can
think about this uh uh encompassing the
earth and having nodes that go all the
way from the surface of the earth all
the way up into the lower stratosphere.
Um and we actually feed in and then
predict in an auto reggressively a
hundred different atmospheric uh
variables for instance uh wind speed,
temperature and humidity as shown here.
Um and this worked very well. Here's a a
quick example. We were excited to see
this um in late 2024. This is Hurricane
Lee. Sort of comes into the Atlantic,
pauses for a moment, and then takes a
takes a a turn to the north, speeds up,
and makes landfall on Nova Scotia. Um
the total this total video is uh nine
days worth. So that's how far the the
hurricane moves. And this is actually
the output of the graph neural network.
That's its prediction. and the
prediction that it made is accurate nine
days out of where that landfall is going
to be. In comparison, the best gold
standard models um that are that are
physics-based were only accurate six
days out as to where that landfall was
going to be. When you're talking about a
major hurricane hitting land, three days
is really important. Um so with this we
said okay this is important and we're
going to keep on pushing the science. So
the team developed the next model we
called this gencast and the difference
here is that this model while also based
on a mesh um is probabilistic and it has
a higher accuracy and a higher
efficiency.
the weather is fundamentally chaotic and
we want to know what's happening um on
the tails and so having a model that's
probabilistic
allows us to do that allows this to be
operationalized and used for actual
weather prediction.
Um Gencast also was more accurate. So
when we compared it to 1300 gold
standard uh benchmarked weather
forecasts then this was more accurate
97% of the time and it was also uh could
be we could produce that 15-day forecast
in eight minutes on a single chip
instead of hours on a very large
supercomput.
So much different sort of space of the
solution that we were proposing. Um and
just this last year this team is
relentless. They're constantly coming up
with new models. Um, and so the latest
one is called FGN,
uh, functional generative network. This
directly predicts cyclones rather than
predicting the weather and then having
to add on a cyclone detector as sort of
post-processing. This actually
incorporates the the categorization, the
recognition of cyclones, their
trajectory, their wind speed, and the
formation of the eye directly into the
network. who train for that which means
that it's much better. Um so this has
already been used um in the US by the
National Hurricane Center. Um and they
are very very excited by how much um of
an advantage this now gives. Um so uh
this this will hopefully be used
worldwide in in the coming years.
All right. Lastly, I wanted to use the
last few minutes to talk about again
something that is not uh language model
based. So this is world models. Um and
this actually came out of work that deep
mind has done on games and simulation
for a long time. Um we've been working
on Atari on Go on Starcraft um and then
on you know Mojoko type environments for
robotics because we wanted to understand
um agency and the environment.
we started focusing more and more on not
just the training the agent but creating
the in an an infinite environment.
You know when we when I did work on a
locomotion here um then oh that's not
playing well
maybe this will play. I'm going to jump
forward to genie one. So we wanted uh so
this is genie one. It could only run for
a few seconds, but you could say, "Hey,
I want this type of a world." And then
you could produce this little platformer
2D game environment where you could jump
around for a few minutes and it would
actually respond to whether you hit the
the left or the right and it could
produce a reasonable diversity of
different looking platformer type of
worlds. This was enough to say, we might
have something here. Let's scale up.
let's scale up the data um and train
again, improve the method
and train again now on 3D games. Then we
produce Genie 2. Genie 2 is uh is
interactive but it's not yet real time
so you need to go awfully slowly. um um
and it can uh produce 3D environments,
but it couldn't do anything that was
really real world type of quality uh and
uh more higher definition.
Um so we were working on that and then
along came
VO3.
All right.
Now
[cheering and applause]
All right. Well, now I am out of time,
but I will still take another another
minute or two to just show show you
these. Um, so this is saying that
telling Genie, I want a world where I'm
walking down a muddy lane in Kent. Um,
this looks not far from my house. The
fun thing here is that you look down at
yourself and you realize that you
actually have a body. You're actually
interacting with the world. It's a
little bit odd to uh to know what's
coming out of this model. It's really
understood not just the appearance of a
lane in Kent, but actually what it takes
to engage with that, make the water
move, and to walk forward. Um, of
course, it's not just scenes that are
walking. We can very happily uh ski um
and so you can create an environment
where you can engage with the world in
so many different different ways.
Um, here's an example where it says
original there. That's we started this,
we prompted this with a fragment of
video and now it's changed to Janie
Genie 3. So, this is an artist. He made
those that those first few seconds and
then we use that to prompt Jeanie and
bring this world to life. He was so
tickled to see that we could take a
little snippet of his world that he had
laboriously created and bring that to
life in a way that means that you can
fly through it. you can bounce off of
this thing and it remembers that oh
here's that here's that weird structure
there and go back to that and fly
through there. [snorts] Um, so these
environments are not only diverse and
interactive, high quality, they also
have uh memory. So the prompt here was
I'm an origami lizard in an origami
world and this is what you get. And we
use this as a nice little test that I
can spend, you know, uh, I can spend a
minute running in one direction, run
back uh, to the start and everything is
exactly as it was at the beginning. um
because we have a really good memory.
Working in these environments gives us
consistency and control.
Um and lastly, we have uh we're able to
prompt this world as you're in it. So
that means that um while I'm in a world
that might be a little bit boring. Here
I am. You know, this is a world saying
I'm walking down the Camden Canal in
London here
uh near the Deep Mind office. Well, what
happens if I prompt it at the same time?
Then what happens?
I've just changed the world that I'm in.
Can change it again.
There we go. Immediately, the world is
is different. And one more time, just
for fun.
I love the idea of a new form of gaming
where I could be adversarially prompting
your experience of a world. It just
creates a whole different sort of um
entertainment, a whole world, a whole
new frontier um that I think can be
really amazing, not just for
entertainment, but for education as
well. Um the ability to be able to go
into a world in order to learn about it,
I think is incredibly powerful. um and
may well be something that that that we
see more and more of. Um and uh with
that I will uh say thank you and just a
quick call out that tomorrow morning um
my colleague Omar is going to talk about
Gemma 4 which is a language model.
[laughter]
Thank you.
[music]